Part C evaluate the second derivative of
y with respect to x squared at the point
on the curve where x equals negative 1
and y is equal to 1 alright so let's
just go to the beginning where they tell
us that dy/dx is equal to y over 3y
squared minus X so let me write that
down
so dy dy DX is equal to Y over 3y
squared minus X 3y squared minus X and
now what I want to do is essentially
take the derivative of both sides again
now there's a bunch of ways that we
could try to tackle it but the way it's
written right now if I take the
derivative of the right-hand side I'm
going to have to apply the quotient rule
which is really just comes from the
product rule but again it gets pretty
hairy so let's see if I can simplify
that might ask a little bit I'm going to
have to do implicit differentiation one
way or the other so what if I multiply
both sides of this times 3y squared
minus X then I get 3y squared minus x
times dy/dx is equal to is equal to Y
and so now taking the derivative of both
sides that this is going to be a little
bit more straightforward in fact if I
want I could well actually let me just
let me just do it like this and so let's
let's apply our derivative operator to
both sides let's give ourselves some
space so I'm going to apply my
derivative operator to both sides and
take the derivative of the left-hand
side with respect to X and the
derivative of the right-hand side with
respect to X and so here I'll apply the
product rule first I'll take the
derivative of this expression and then
multiply that times dy/dx and they'll
take the derivative of this expression
and multiply it times this so the
derivative of 3y squared minus X with
respect to X well that is going to be so
if I take the derivative of 3y squared
with respect to Y it's going to be 6y
and then I have to take the derivative
of Y with respect to
so x dy/dx as we say and this is
completely unfamiliar to you and i
encourage you to watch the several
videos on Khan Academy on implicit
differentiation which is really just an
extension of the chain rule I took the
derivative of 3y squared with respect to
Y and took the derivative of Y with
respect to X now if I take the
derivative of negative x with respect to
X that's going to be negative one fair
enough and so I took the derivative of
this I'm going to multiply it times that
so x dy/dx and then to that I'm going to
add the derivative of this with respect
to X well that's just going to be the
second derivative of Y with respect to x
times this and all I did is applied the
product rule 3y squared minus x once
again I'll say the third time derivative
of this times this plus the derivative
of this times that alright that's going
to be equal to on the right hand side
derivative of Y with respect to X is
just dy/dx
now if I want to I could solve for d the
second derivative of Y with respect to X
but could what could be even better than
that is if I if I substitute everything
else with numbers because then it's just
going to be a nice easy numerical
equation to solve so we know that what
we want to figure out our second
derivative when Y is equal to 1 so Y is
equal to 1 so that's going to be equal
to 1 and this is going to be equal to 1
X is equal to negative 1 so let me
underline that X is equal to negative 1
so X is negative 1 are there any other
X's here and what's dy/dx
well dy DX dy DX is going to be equal to
1 over 3 times 1 which is 3
minus minus negative 1 so this is equal
to 1/4 in fact that's I think where we
evaluated in the beginning yep at the
point negative 1 comma 1 at the point
negative 1 comma 1 so that's dy DX is
1/4 so this is 1/4
this is 1/4 and this is a 1/4 and now we
can solve for the second consult for the
second derivative it's going to make
sure I don't make any careless mistakes
so 6 times 1 times 1/4 is going to be 1
point 5 or 6 well 6 times 1 times 1/4 is
6/4 minus 1 is going to be so 6/4 minus
4/4 is 2/4 so this is going to be 1/2
times 1/4 times 1/4
that's this over here plus the second
derivative of Y with respect to X and
here I have 1 minus negative 1 so it's 1
plus 1 so times 2 so maybe I'll write it
this way plus plus 2 times the second
derivative of Y with respect to X is
equal to is equal to 1/4 and so let's
see I have 1/8 plus 2 times the second
derivative is equal to 1/4
and let's see I could subtract 1 8 from
both sides so subtract 1/8 subtract
1/8 these cancel I get 2 times the
second derivative of Y with respect to X
is equal to 1/4 the same thing as two
eighths the two eighths minus 1/8 is 1/8
then I can divide both sides by 2 and we
get it a little bit of a drum roll here
you divide both sides by 2 or you could
say multiply both sides times 1/2 and
you are going to get you're going to get
the second derivative of Y with respect
to X when X is negative 1 and Y is equal
to 1 is 1 over 16 and we're done